l'élection régionale alliance avec le
front national le président de la
république en direct sur france 2 à 20
heures
présidence des conseils régionaux la
région provence alpes côte d'azur passe
à gauche à toulouse et à rouen les
président rpr udf élu avec les voix du
fn démissionne à paris et un est réglé
le vaccin contre l'hépatite b peut-il se
révéler dangereux il est actuellement
sous haute surveillance
fallait-il vacciner systématiquement
c'est notre enquête de ce soir le
titanic pour et triomphé aux oscars
d'hollywood après un succès mondial
l'exemple en egypte où les censeurs
officiels n'ont pu empêcher sa
présentation
madame monsieur bonsoir dans quelques
instants le président de la république
jacques chirac s'adressera aux français
sur france 2 sans aucun doute pour tirer
les enseignements des récentes élections
régionales et cantonales et parler
également du séisme politique qu'elles
ont provoqué au sein de la droite entre
ceux qui ont accepté ou refusé les
alliances avec le front national
en attendant son intervention
aujourd'hui avait lieu cinq nouvelles
élections à la présidence de conseils
régionaux et ce lundi contrairement à ce
qui s'était passé vendredi les consignes
des états-majors parisiens du rpr et de
l'udf ont été globalement respectée
j'ai vite à la région paca bascule à
gauche
le maire socialiste d'arles michel
vauzelle décroche la présidence à la
majorité relative
la droite s'est déchiré en provence
françois léotard résolument hostile à
tout marchandage avec le front national
n'a pas fait le plein des voix jean
marie le pen lui n'a obtenu que les
suffrages des 37 conseillers est fait en
midi-pyrénées l'udf marc censi a
démissionné aussitôt réélu la majorité
qu'il avait acquise au troisième tour
comprenait les voix d'extrême droite
à l'instigation du leader local du fn
bernard antony l'adversaire socialiste
de marc censi
martin malvy a salué la décision
l'élection du président de région est
reporté scénario identique en
haute-normandie le rpr jean paul gauzès
avait battu la gauche grâce à l'appoint
des suffrages fn installé dans son
fauteuil de président il suspend la
séance
et finalement ce soir il annonce sa
démission tout est à refaire ici hausse
en ile de france enfin rien n'est encore
joué jean paul huchon a réuni les voix
de gauche au premier tour mais les
suspensions de séance se multiplient en
europe votera que dans la soirée la
candidate du rpr dominique versini se
représente
jean yves le gallou pour le front
national et dans l'en but score et puis
ajoutons simplement qu'à la réunion
c'est le communiste paul vergès qui a
été élue maintenant nous allons écouter
donc le président de la république
jacques chirac
mes chers compatriotes les circonstances
actuelles me conduisent à sortir de la
réserve qu'exige ma fonction
parce que j'ai le sentiment que l'on est
en train de perdre le sens des choses
parce que j'ai le sentiment que les
passions se substitue à la raison parce
que j'ai le sentiment que l'on risque
d'abîmer la france ses valeurs son image
garant de la cohésion nationale
je voudrais d'abord rappeler que notre
patrie tire sa force sa grandeur son
unité des valeurs de liberté d'égalité
de fraternité dont elle est porteuse
c'est pour cela que notre pays est
respecté dans le monde je voudrais aussi
rappeler que la politique dans une
démocratie c'est l'honnêteté et le
respect de l'autre que la politique
c'est défendre un idéal c'est être au
service de ses concitoyens que la fin ne
serait en aucun cas justifier les moyens
qu'il faut en toute circonstance un
esprit de responsabilité et de vigilance
à la droite républicaine je voudrais
dire qu'elle peut convaincre sans se
renier
elle a pris des engagements maintes fois
répété au terme desquelles elle
n'accepterait aucune compromission avec
l'extrême droite
ces engagements doivent être respectés
dans la lettre mais aussi dans l'esprit
si je tiens à rendre hommage à tous ceux
qui ont fait preuve de courage et de
clairvoyance
je ne peux que désapprouver celles ou
ceux qui ont préféré les jeux politiques
à la voix de leur conscience
cette attitude même si elle répond à la
volonté de faire barrage à l'adversaire
n'est pas dit
et elle peut être dangereuse à la gauche
je voudrais dire qu'elle devrait être
plus mesuré dans ses jugements plus
responsable dans ses critiques tant il
est vrai qu'il est malsain de jeter de
l'huile sur le feu depuis longtemps
certains n'ont pas hésité à faire le jeu
de l'extrême droite
c'est ainsi que le scrutin proportionnel
a été adopté c'est ainsi que lors des
dernières élections législatives
de nombreux sièges ont été donnés à la
gauche par un front national qui a
clairement et délibérément fait battre
la droite républicaine au profit de
l'actuelle majorité
je voudrais enfin dire aux électeurs du
front national qu'ils doivent eux aussi
mesurer leur responsabilité volts il
s'enfermer dans un vote protestataire
acceptent-ils le risque de voter pour un
parti de nature raciste et xénophobe
ce qui est la réalité actuelle du front
national ou bien vont-ils appartenir à
un mouvement politique incarnant une
droite traditionnelle mais respectueux
des valeurs de la république et sa
compatriote une loi électorale inadaptée
que tous les responsables politiques de
notre pays ont eu le grand tort de ne
pas changer a révélé un peu plus encore
la confusion des esprits et le manque de
conviction et d'ardeur cette situation
qui conduit un nombre croissant de
français à se détourner de la vie
politique n'est pas acceptable dans un
pays profondément touchés par le chômage
et l'exclusion est confronté au choix de
l'avenir c'est
de donner à notre peuple
de plus en plus critique et aux
étrangers de plus en plus surpris le
spectacle d'une vie politique plus
soumise aux intérêts particuliers qu'aux
exigences légitimes des français et aux
intérêts de la france
aujourd'hui le temps est venu de réagir
la france pays pionniers pays phare des
libertés doit rester fidèle à son idéal
le temps est venu de moderniser notre
vie politique et de l'adapter à son
époque notre vie politique doit être
plus proche des citoyens plus
transparents mieux répondre aux
exigences de la morale et de
l'efficacité
le renouvellement des élus un nombre
accru de femmes dans la vie publique
réforme de certaines lois électorales
celle des cumuls la place du référendum
local ou national bien d'autres
changements encore s'impose aujourd'hui
sur tous ces sujets j'entends conduire
une grande réflexion je recevrai dans
les prochaines semaines les responsables
des formations politiques républicaines
je m'entoure raid et à vis des
personnalités les plus qualifiés je
dirais alors ce que je crois bon pour
notre pays de l'épreuve que traverse
notre vie politique
sachant tirer l'énergie l'imagination et
la force pour dessiner le visage de la
démocratie française de demain
vive la république et vive la france
voilà donc pour l'intervention de
jacques chirac qu'arlette chabot déjà un
commentaire oui alors si tu médites la
république a décidé de parler de
s'adresser de façon extrêmement
solennelle aux français ce soir c'est
parce qu'à ses yeux effectivement il y
avait urgence il y a eu la fin de
l'interdît d'alliance avec le front
national
la confusion totale
dans les esprits dans l'opposition mais
aussi un peu dans la majorité et puis
l'image de la france qui est sans doute
enterré il suffisait de voir les
commentaires de la presse étrangère
alors le président de la république est
tout à fait dans son rôle ce soir
lorsqu'il s'adresse aux français pour
leur demander de se rassembler sur les
valeurs fortes qui fonde notre
démocratie et notre république liberté
égalité fraternité
lorsqu'il rappelle aux politiques en
aucun cas à la fin les justifier les
moyens est aussi dans son rôle lorsqu'il
admoneste tout le monde
la droite en lui rappelant qu'elle peut
convaincre sans se renier et en laissant
entendre qu'il souhaiterait lui que ceux
qui ont été élu avec des voix du front
national démissionne lorsqu'il s'adresse
aussi à la gauche en lui demandant
d'être plus mesuré dans ses jugements
plus responsable dans ses critiques de
ne pas jeter de l'huile sur le feu une
critique indirecte à l'égard du premier
ministre était intervenu jeudi dernier
et enfin quand il s'adresse directement
aux électeurs du front national en
qualifiant leur parti encore une fois du
raciste et xénophobe et en les invitant
à rejoindre la droite traditionnelle et
puis surtout ce qui est important c'est
tout ça débouche évidemment sur une très
grande réforme de nos institutions
pas uniquement le mode de scrutin des
régionales qui aujourd'hui fait
l'unanimité contre lui
mais plus généralement le président
demande une réforme plus large de la vie
politique le cumul des mandats la place
des femmes
le référendum également il mènera
lui-même cette concertation en recevant
tous les responsables des partis sans le
front national on comprend bien et ce
soir visiblement jacques chirac lance
qui sera une des grandes affaires de son
septennat
merci arlette dans un instant réactions
politiques sur ce plateau avec françois
hollande ou encore philippe douste-blazy
monsieur robert hue du parti communiste
et jean marie le pen du front national
en attendant revenons aux élections de
présidents de conseils régionaux qui
avait donc été repoussée de vendredi à
aujourd'hui dans des régions plus que
délicate visiblement les états majors de
la droite rpr udf ont été entendus cette
fois ci il n'y a pas eu globalement de
dérapage dans les quatre régions qui
devaient tenir leur président à
commencer par l'île de france ou de même
les choses sont assez compliqué ce soir
jean baptiste vey dali rien rien n'est
réglé
non rien n'est réglé pour l'instant
alors si jean paul huchon le candidat
socialiste
a fait le plein des voix de gauche au
premier tour il n'en est pas de même à
droite pour la candidate rpr udf
dominique versini alors pour l'instant
on est dans une suspension de séance
avant le deuxième tour donc pour dans
quelques instants
et on s'achemine vers 3 tours et une
longue soirée alors au troisième tour si
les choses ne sont pas clarifiées à
droite roger karoutchi le président du
groupe rpr ici en ile-de-france évoqué
la possibilité de ne pas présenter de
candidat
voilà la séance va reprendre à l'instant
mais je vous propose de revenir sur les
événements et les surprises du jour avec
véronique saint-helier 2000 à avoir
séché le lycée et la pac pour venir
crier leur refus du front national à
quelques mètres de là en début d'après
midi
arithmétiquement c'est jean paul huchon
candidat de la majorité plurielle qui
tient la corde
dominique versini elle porte les
couleurs prdf pour l'honneur elle s'est
engagée à ne pas accepter les voix du
front national
le gaullisme c'est le refus de la
fatalité
voilà c'est pour ça que je suis là et je
veux poursuivre et défaut d'un programme
la majorité des voix par les payer au
siège pour la première fois ne
s'intéresse qu'à la mort du grand
capital
c'est donc jean yves le gallou candidat
du front national qui va se charger de
brouiller les cartes
ce qui est en mon pouvoir pour empêcher
le ps et le pc les amis de polpot de
lénine de prendre le conseil régional de
l'île de france
16h dans l'hémicycle chaque camp- ces
coupes
on s'informe de la situation dans les
autres régions charles pasqua
président de séance lance le premier
tour de scrutin 17h30 surprise la gauche
fait le plein de ses voix le front
national aussi
mais il manque 10 9 voix à la candidate
de l'opposition
suspension de séance
tu peux avoir peur de tout
mais on est en tête explication des
gravures au groupe rpr udf pour certains
l'university n'aurait pas suffisamment
attaqué la gauche dans sa déclaration de
candidature ou remettre les pendules à
l'heure il est 19h30 le deuxième tour du
scrutin ne commencera qu'après
l'intervention du président de la
république région explosive sur le plan
politique également provence alpes côte
d'azur tout là bas c'est terminé
finalement plus simplement que prévu par
l'élection ce matin du socialiste michel
vauzelle le front national avec à sa
tête jean marie le pen n'étant pas
parvenue finalement à débaucher la
droite rpr udf reportage
jacques cardoze jean-françois jean jé
satisfaction et soulagement dans les
rangs de la gauche plurielle
trois jours après le début du premier
scrutin l'assemblée régionale provence
alpes côte d'azur a fini par élire le
successeur de jean claude gaudin mais la
journée des tractations vendredi a
laissé des traces divisant la droite
classique et dans son discours michel
vauzelle devra salué l'attitude digne
est clair dit-il de françois léotard
je souhaite dire également mon respect
aux élus de la droite républicaine
ils ont su démontrer dans des moments
difficiles leur fidélité aux valeurs qui
fondent notre république monsieur
françois léotard pour la région dans les
bouches du rhône
monsieur jean-françois maclean
applaudissements et huées partage
l'assemblée à l'image du vote car
françois léotard a payé cher son
attitude
seuls 19 élus rpr udf l'on suive film
français qui veulent s'attacher à
reconstruire une opposition républicaine
dean démocratique est bien l'homme
réfléchir à la façon de faire se
regrouper et faire en sorte que nous
puissions montrer qu'il peut y avoir de
la dignité dans le débat comme certains
conseillers régionaux souhaitait marquer
leur désaccord avec françois léotard le
président de l'udf ne semble plus faire
l'unanimité dans son propre camp je peux
vous dire que notre unité est intact et
que nous serons un des groupes et
combatif de cette assemblée régionale
derrière consoler au tarbes derrière
conçoit les autres
certainement pas cela prouve que lorsque
le rpr et l'udf veulent jouer ni la
gauche ni le front national elle fait
passer la gauche est elle disparaît à
l'issue du scrutin plusieurs centaines
de militants anti frontiste s'étaient
donné rendez-vous celui dit soulagé de
pouvoir saluer michel vauzelle pour
midi-pyrénées maintenant l'udf marc
censi a d'abord été élu avec les voix du
front national
ensuite comme cela s'était passé en
franche comté la semaine dernière il a
démissionné d'élection est donc reporté
christophe l'avocat albert miclo si marx
ainsi à chaque voix qui porte son nom
marx ô marx ainsi semble un peu plus a
battu au troisième tour il en obtient 48
ans ainsi celle de la droite en totalité
plus vite et mal du sud du front
national face au socialiste martin malvy
cinéma lui donne la majorité
huit voies qui vont entraîner sa
démission le résultat du scrutin ne me
paraît pas de nature à réunir les
conditions nécessaires à une gestion
sereine et efficace de leur restitution
dans ces conditions je préfère présenter
ma démission et faire appel dans
l'intérêt de l'ue
submergé par l'émotion marc censi aura
les plus grandes difficultés à terminer
son discours
épilogue d'une journée tendue commencé
le matin par la manifestation à
l'extérieur des opposants au front
national et qui s'est poursuivi toute la
journée de conciliabules en aparté et ce
soir côté les radicaux de gauche sont
volontaires pour constituer un pont
entre la droite et la gauche les
radicaux souhaitent que l'on réfléchisse
à la situation et que les conditions
soient créées en midi pyrénées pour
élire un président en dehors du front
national je sais pas du tout comment ça
ça peut s'appeler une réunion de
personnes de bonne volonté qui soit
solidariser par une même vision de la
région et une même volonté de son
intérêt de son développement qui sait
l'avenir le dira c'est du tout autour de
martin malvy le candidat désigné par le
parti socialiste d'accuser le coup
l'élection du président de la région est
reporté entre le 2 et le 6 avril les
élus de la région midi pyrénées ont donc
désormais dix jours pour se mettre
d'accord sur une candidature disons
consensuelle les radicaux de gauche
seront à cet égard particulièrement
courtisés
la décision sera prise ici à toulouse
mais évidemment aussi à paris auprès du
gouvernement de lionel jospin
et puis encore en haute-normandie donc
même scénario le rpr jean paul goze a
été élu au troisième tour avec les voix
du front national
il a immédiatement démissionné reportage
guilaine chenu frédéric bonnet c'est un
homme de droite qui s'assoit quelques
instants dans ce fauteuil de président
grâce aux voix du front national
le scénario a déjà été rodé dans
plusieurs régions mais à l'ouverture de
la séance il reste quelques incertitudes
comme le nom du candidat de droite
antoine ruffenach démissionnaire du rpr
ne se représente pas c'est donc jean
paul gauzès qui tente sa chance avec un
programme qui intègre les conditions de
entendez par le front national est ce
que la droite va accepter les voies du
fou
incertitude aussi sur l'attitude du
front national il est l'arbitré de ce
scrutin et semble vouloir faire payer à
la droite son attitude dans la région
provence alpes côte d'azur racisme à
l'égard de refuser système est le voit
et quand on lui donne une vie amoureuse
a surtout pas demander la partie se joue
en trois tours avec une surprise dès le
premier puisque quatre voies de droite
se reforme sur le candidat de gauche
j'ai peur que cet après-midi un
après-midi du peu tel que c'est parti
puisque visiblement ya pas la carte et
dans le bol des uns et des autres les
voies et gares et retrouve le chemin de
la droite dès le deuxième tour et le
dénouement est pour le troisième le
front national présente son candidat
c'est à l'heure il reporte toutes ces
voix sur les bancs de la gauche on vient
de comprendre
jean paul gauzès est élu avec toutes les
voix du front national dans la mesure où
monsieur coges après clairement demandé
nos voix par sa déclaration contre dur
il était normal que nous l'apporterons
les réactions sont immédiates à ce
moment l'élection est joué mais le
suspense dure
le nouveau président demande une
suspension de séance d'une heure
à son retour il annonce sa démission oui
belle à notre conviction commune que
nous avons su toujours démontrée je
démissionne
en haute-normandie aussi après une
journée de suspense et de
rebondissements
il faudra rejouer cette élection alors
la carte des régions se complètent donc
ce soir avec la région paca qui est donc
désormais à gauche pour ce qui concerne
vous l'avez compris midi-pyrénées
ile-de-france haute-normandie et la
franche comté pour l'instant rien n'est
dernières élections date d'ailleurs
celle du communiste paul vergès à la
réunion il a battu le candidat udf jean
paul virapoullé
parmi les cinq membres de l'udf qui ont
accepté la semaine dernière les voix du
front national pour occuper un poste de
président de région
celui qui provoque sans nul doute le
plus de réactions
c'est charles millon en rhône alpes des
pressions se sont exercées sur lui
jusqu'au président la république dit on
pour qu'il démissionne
une nouvelle après-midi difficile
aujourd'hui pour chats mignons dans sa
ville de belley dans l'ain dont il est
le maire un conseil municipal très
délicat benoît gadret jean claude martin
une séance de conseil municipal
particulièrement houleuse charles millon
n'a pas voulu reporter la réunion
il est même allé au devant des
manifestants qui lui barrait le chemin à
l'ordre du jour le marché de l'eau de la
ville de belley mais à peine la séance
ouverte
les élus de gauche demandaient la parole
le maire de gaulle air car j'ai toute
crédibilité ainsi que l'autorité que lui
avait confiée est conféré le suffrage
universel
vos concitoyens et pour un profond
sentiment de honte se traduire par un
cinglant désaveu désaveu puisque le
premier adjoint de charlot mignon était
battu hier au deuxième tour dans ce
canton ancré à droite devant la mairie
quelques 450 manifestants
les élus de gauche mais aussi des
électeurs de charles millon des citoyens
surtout par l'attitude de leur mère
je suis aujourd'hui terminé j'ai brûlé
les ailes là croyez-moi dans une liste
où c'est alors qu'ils n'étaient pas
acceptées ambiance après vingt minutes
de chahut charles millon a mis fin à la
séance
au risque de nourrir encore la confusion
dans une tribune publiée aujourd'hui
dans le journal le monde
il demande la constitution d'une
formation unique de la droite pour faire
barrage à l'extrême droite
l'appel a déplu à jean marie le pen le
président du front national demande ce
soir la démission de charles millon
monsieur le pen lui-même demande
d'admission ce qui démontre que je n'ai
fait aucune concession ni sur les
valeurs ni sur la vie politique
quotidienne la journée de demain
s'annonce tout aussi agité pour charles
millon qui doit former l'exécutif
régional
après les régionales pour être tout à
fait complet maintenant voici leurs
résultats définitifs du second tour des
élections cantonales à gauche a
bénéficié
visiblement de la crise de l'opposition
récupérant une dizaine de départements
en réalisant un score global très très
satisfaisant le meilleur en tout cas
depuis la fondation de la vème
république au lit des 40 à peine plus
d'un français sur deux a fait ce geste
hier pour le second tour des élections
cantonales et pour savoir qui a boudé
les urnes
il suffit de regarder les résultats
nationaux
avec plus de 900 conseillers généraux la
gauche plurielle double son score de 92
elle fait pratiquement jeu égal avec
l'ensemble rpr udf et divers droite en
pleine polémique sur les accords avec le
fn
les élus de droite n'ont pas réussi à
mobiliser leur électorat bilan plus de
trois cent soixante d'entre eux perdent
leurs sièges dont les anciens ministres
colette codaccioni jean jacques de
peretti eric raoult tu cette
démobilisation à aider la gauche à
conquérir dix départements que la droite
dirigée par fois depuis plus de 15 ans
la majorité gouvernementale enregistre
donc des progrès sensibles
à droite on pourra toujours se consoler
en notant que l'opposition reste à la
tête de deux départements sur trois nos
invités ce soir donc à la fois pour
commenter des déclarations du plaignant
d'un public et voir ce que l'on doit
penser ce soir de ces élections
régionales des élections de présidents
de conseils régionaux
françois hollande au nom du parti
socialiste
douste-blazy idf monsieur robert hue
parti communiste qui est avec nous
bonsoir et monsieur jean marie le pen et
on va commencer par vous qui êtes ici en
ma compagnie françois hollande d'abord à
propos de la déclaration de jacques
chirac
bien entendu il a étalé les fautes je
dirais de chaque côté la fin ne justifie
pas les moyens quant à un accord avec le
front national du côté de l'opposition
de la droite mais en même temps la
gauche a jeté de l'huile sur le feu et
il a un peu redit que c'était la gauche
finalement qu'il y avait inventé front
national
enfin il l'a dit parce qu'il avait
surtout un message à faire passer à la
droite
il était temps d'ailleurs que le
président de la république s'essaye à
faire cesser la crise que traverse la
droite dans ses rapports avec l'extrême
droite et je crois qu'il a eu des mots
utiles et des mots bienvenus en effet en
disant que le front national était un
parti raciste et xénophobe et en disant
que certains de ses propres amis avaient
sans doute perdu leur âme
il les a conduits je pense qu'ils en
tireront les leçons a refusé l'alliance
avec l'extrême droite et sans doute les
cinq qui ont été élus avec les voix de
l'extrême droite a démissionné c'était
ça le message et je crois qu'il était
très important a prononcé vis-à-vis de
la droite qui s'était fourvoyé avec
l'écrit la barre de la faute sur la
gauche
écoutez c'est un débat ancien moi ce que
je constate c'est que pour le moment la
gauche à la confiance des français
c'était le résultat des élections
cantonales
et je ne vois pas pourquoi le président
de la république aurait raison et il a
eu raison de mettre en garde ses propres
amis par rapport à la tentation de
l'extrême droite et pourquoi le premier
ministre et la gauche aurait tort
lorsqu'il demande la même chose sur le
sol asie vous avez compris quoi ce soir
de l'intervention du ponant public torts
partagés dans les accords avec le front
national
je partage point par point ce qu'a dit
le président de la république qui s'est
montré ce soir le garant de la cohésion
nationale surtout le garant de
l'indivisibilité de la république est
allé au delà il est allé au delà en
rappelant les les grands principes de la
démocratie l'égalité entre les citoyens
le respect du suffrage universel et
surtout peut-être le plus important est
la dignité des élus et je crois qu'il
apparaît comme le gars ont dû passer
républicaine notre passé les publics là
dessus de notre pays mais en meute on
est surtout il apparaît que le reste
viendrait venir du pays je dirais en
disant que la fin ne justifie pas les
moyens il s'en est principalement pris à
l'udf
ce que les cinq présidents qui se sont
fait élire la semaine dernière sont de
l'udf c'est dur contre vous contre votre
confédération nous avons été très clair
puisqu'il y aura des exclusions avec
françois bayrou nous l'avons dit à
plusieurs reprises
vous savez ce soir quand même il faut
quand même parler de marc censi aussi de
monsieur vous êtes de ceux qui ont été
courageux que montrer l'exemplarité
ce soir je dirais que la démocratie a
donné une leçon au front national
mais monsieur hollande à partir de ce
soir plus de leçons de morale
moi je ne connais pas encore de
président lui qui en a fait une invasion
de la fin non mais je vous dis
aujourd'hui après les démissions qu'il
ya eu jeudi ce soir avec force et cela
n'était que la démocratie a donné une
leçon au front national et à ceux qui
donnent trop souvent de deux ans nous
mourrons
le président a eu raison de dire que la
gauche
mettez de l'huile sur le feu ce sont ses
termes mais je crois que maintenant ce
soir après après l'avoir entendu il faut
peut-être arrêter
il reste cinq présidents de région de
votre mouvement qui ont passé une
alliance avec l'extrême je me félicite
comme vous vous avez très quand ils
auront démissionner oui bien entendu que
ceux qui n'ont pas accepté les voix du
front national eric notre salut c'est
tout à fait normal mais que ceux qui les
a acceptées mérite notre leçon je le
crains eh bien oui il faut en tirer
leçon aussi il faut qu'il démissionne
une seconde messieurs je voudrais
m'adresser maintenant jean marie le pen
monsieur le pen bonsoir bonsoir bien
alors ce soir monsieur le pen si je puis
dire vous en avez pris pour votre grade
de la part du président la république il
s'est adressé à vous en parlant de
partis racistes et xénophobes très durs
à l'encontre du front national oui
en prononçant ces accusations le
président de la république s'est conduit
de façon infâme diffamatoires et
mensongères c'est très facile duo de
l'elysée d'accuser ses adversaires
politiques de ne pas correspondre aux
définitions de la république et de la
moralité
alors que la république de monsieur
chirac ses amis et lui même sont
probablement les dirigeants les plus
immoraux que la france ait jamais connu
nous n'avons pas
de leçon de république à nîmes ni de
démocratie à recevoir de monsieur eu de
monsieur chirac ou de monsieur jospin ce
sont les citoyens ce sont les électeurs
qui détermine la qualité républicaines
et démocratiques et personne d'autre et
surtout pas des adversaires politiques
moi je demande aux français de
s'interroger sur la puissance la nature
de la puissance secrète qui prient tous
les hommes politiques comme des
spaghettis chaud à ses volontés il
monsieur drac un jour sur youtube
l'aisne à part ce soir résonne cette
comparution cette comparaison culinaire
une autre une autre question que
certains apprécieront
une autre question tout même aujourd'hui
vaut pas combinaison non pas au sens
péjoratif mais vos efforts en région
paca pour essayer de passer vous même en
tant que président de région ont échoué
aujourd'hui dans les quatre régions
concernées il n'y a pas eu de succès des
des tentatives du front national vous
êtes déçu mais monsieur nous sommes nous
représentons 25 ou 30 % des voix en paca
nous sommes donc minoritaire nous avons
simplement demandé que la vie publique
dans ces collectivités locales
s'organisent autour de la recherche
d'une majorité majorité vrai car ces
seuls la majorité réelle qui peut donner
une légitimité aux actes du pouvoir
régional et ceux qui étaient scandaleux
c'est qu'il avait été convenu à
l'avant-centre les partie de la bande
des quatre que la région serait laissée
à celui d'entre eux qui arriverait en
tête et chlorés bat pas on va parler
vélo créative
on va pas se développer vous développez
coûté si vous m'invitez à dire ce que
l'on attendait ça n'est pas pour dire
dans les maquis si on est des mains de
monsieur hollande mais monsieur le pen
ma question n'était pas celle là elle
était en fait je vous demande si vous
étiez déçu de ne pas avoir réussi votre
opération pas calmé répondra je le suis
je ne suis pas déçu mais quand moi moi
j'obtiens j'obtiens 37 voix et monsieur
et monsieur les hôtes à celle de de
l'udf obtient 19 voix dont vous n'avez
pas à ce qu'est la réalité la droite est
en pleine déroute
et d'ailleurs pour que le président de
la république se soit cru obligé de
faire cette démarche insolite est
inconstitutionnelle et insupportable
c'est probablement parce qu'il prouve
que la situation est très dangereuse
merci le penser mais reçu le masque doré
monsieur le maire remercie parce que
vous n'êtes pas souffrir
laissez moi alors un mot parce que je
commençais mon retour n'est pas tout
c'est que vont penser les français de
cette mobilisation de tous les partis
politiques du premier ministre et du
président de la république contre un
parti politique dont ils disent qu'ils
ne représentent que 15% des électeurs
il ya là quelque chose absolument
insensé merci monsieur le pen alors il
n'en est pas obligé d'être long pour
être bon monsieur robert hue bonsoir
votre point de vue sur donc d'abord la
déclaration du chef de l'état écoutez le
président de la république a voulu
prendre de la hauteur par rapport à la
situation que nous connaissons personne
peut lui reprocher il est clair en même
temps que le président de la république
a vu ce qui s'était passé hier une de
nombreux français ont condamné sans
appel
eh bien ces alliances indigne qui ont
été passés entre une partie de la droite
et front national et donc il a il ay là
il se devait effectivement d'intervenir
parce que le président de la république
naturellement dans son rôle et il se
place au dessus des partis politiques là
mais mais mais c'est quand même ce sont
ses amis qui ont été conduits à c'est à
ces magouilles et conduit ses magouilles
et regarde ce soir avec intérêt il
l'avait déjà fait l'an fin de semaine
dernière une étude de président du
présent d'art public que tout à fait
digne et qui condamne sans appel ces
magouilles
je crois que il me semble les choses ont
bougé quand on entend monsieur le pen
s'énerver ont recours on comprend qu
effectivement le piège qu'il a tendu il
s'est refermé en partie sur certains
mais sur d'autres on voit qu'il ya une
prise de distance
monsieur le pen a en fait depuis des
années fait son fond de commerce en
disant regardez ces partis politiques
ils ont ils ont ils magouillent là il a
été pris l'ailé la main dans le sac
regardez les magouilles qui l'a conduit
donc ils viennent par des français qu'on
réagit bien merci monsieur verrue alors
jour et revenir simplement un mais deux
invités si françois hollande est
simplement un mot et de philippe
douste-blazy également un mot sur la
réforme du scrutin réforme de scrutin au
lendemain d'une élection c'est toujours
ce qu'on dit aux hommes politiques vous
auriez pu y penser avant oui bien sûr et
le chef de l'état on a d'ailleurs fait
la confession tous les responsables et
notamment ceux qui ont gouverné le pays
pendant quatre ans et ils étaient
concernés auraient dû changer le mode de
scrutin nous ne pouvions pas après les
élections du mois de juin on n'avait pas
en six ans noah écoutez moi je pense
qu'il faut saisir en tout cas l'occasion
d'offrir la réplique à 10 réforme du
mode de scrutin limitation du cumul des
mandats
nous y sommes favorables place des
femmes parité hommes femmes dans les
instituions nous y sommes favorables
et s'il faut aller plus loin notamment
sur la durée des mandats nous pensons
qu'il faut les raccourcir et les
harmoniser
eh bien pourquoi pas l'on tire de tout
ce spectacle qui était effectivement
assez désagréable à regarder et bien que
l'on tire plutôt une réforme positive
nous nous sommes prêts à jouer le jeu de
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui dans les
quatre élections qu'on a vu où chacun
s'est comporté comme le demandaient les
états majors les chefs de partis des
chefs de file
c'est ce qui aurait dû se passer la
semaine dernière ça veut dire que notre
ligne gagne que la démocratie ce soir à
gagner je voudrais quand même revenir
sur la modernisation de la vie politique
des pratiques politiques également sur
le cumul des mandats
oui à condition qu'il y ait un statut de
l'élu et à condition que l'on se mette
ensemble au delà des clivages pour que
la démocratie puisse résister car sinon
si on fait d'un côté on voit toujours
lendemain on fait des majorités qui
n'ont rien à voir avec le vote
uniquement pour la politique
politicienne c'est le retour la
quatrième république
donc vous souhaitons une modernisation
de la vie politique c'est ça qui est le
plus important ce soir
merci messieurs merci à tous nos invités
l'actualité de ce jour c'est encore la
rentrée des classes à hénin beaumont
dans le pas de calais pour les camarades
de la petite ludivine assassiné la
semaine dernière au cours d'un séjour en
classe de neige le cuisinier du centre
où était hébergé les enfants ayant
reconnu les faits la question qui se
pose désormais est de savoir comment il
a pu opérer pendant la nuit sans que
personne n'intervienne ne soit alerté
d'une quelconque façon reportage
virginie fiche est de mise sur leurs
anoraks la photo de ludivine malheureux
depuis hier isabelle et marie france
collecte de l'argent dans le quartier
pour offrir une dernière gerbe de fleurs
à la fillette
la fille de marie france ariel 11 ans
partageait la chambre de ludivine la
nuit du drame étaient produits qu'ils
vivent et puis a été dans la salle de
bain et après baiia et la lutte j'ai vu
qu'elle voulait crier mis à venir ça de
voir n'y a mis sa main devant sa bouche
j'attendais taper dans le mur et
monsieur par ma boutique de paul
si tu bouges et bagarres à toi comment
qu'est ce que j'ai fait manger pages où
j'ai pas bougé
et puis j'ai pas crier une fois son
crime commis le meurtrier présumé
mais en examen hier aurait ainsi
terrorisé d'autres enfants
ce qui expliquerait qu'aucun d'eux n'est
donné l' alerte
on sait que des enfants comme les
adultes d'ailleurs tenu à tresses un
événement très stressant nous
grande intensité au niveau du vécu et de
l'angoissé peuvent être dans un état où
n'arrive plus agir on n'arrive plus donc
par exemple l'occurrence à crier à se
défendre à se débattre selon des sources
proches de l'anc est le divine serait la
seule à avoir tenté de résister
craignant d'être dénoncé l'homme
l'aurait alors tué selon la défense
d'autres enfants auraient crié les
avocats du jeune cuisinier ne
comprennent pas et met en cause le
personnel d'encadrement pendant trois
quatre heures l'intéressé a évolué et
libres de toute contingence en pleine
nuit à l'intérieur d'un établissement
des personnels qui sont professionnels
de surcroît des professionnels qui
aiment leurs responsabilités et les
enfants sont habitués à sortir au
moindre cauchemar d'un enfant ils n'ont
rien entendu
ils n'ont rien entendu des enfants
ont-ils vraiment tenté de donner
l'alerté dans ces circonstances les
adultes n'ont ils pas réagi à temps
l'enquète administratives et surtout la
reconstitution des faits devrait lever
le doute
rennes le meurtrier de la petite karine
s'est vu réclamer contre lui une peine
de prison à perpétuité pour viol et
meurtre de cette petite fille de 11 ans
à la veille de l'examen en conseil des
ministres de la loi contre l'exclusion
les organisations de chômeurs tentent de
reprendre leur action spectaculaire
aujourd'hui à paris une trentaine de
personnes clés mais pendant quelques
temps l'antenne a séduit manifestation
dans une trentaine de villes également
comme nantes metz et puis également à
bordeaux au reportage david bazié franck
vaillant
oui il est toujours occupée nous sommes
des citoyens comme les autres ils sont
compris je n'entre ici c'est lui qui
parlait de citoyenneté en tant que
citoyenne je tiens à parler monsieur
jospin passé le mois ci lui plaît
journée d'occupation journée au
téléphone pour ces militants d'agir
contre le chômage
toute la journée ils ont tenté de
joindre le chef du gouvernement par tous
les moyens même en se faisant passer
pour la fille du président de la
république
car le gouvernement prépare son projet
de loi contre l'exclusion
les grandes lignes dévoilées par lionel
jospin n'ont pas convaincu les
associations pour lutter contre
l'exclusion il faut donner envie aux
gens parce que tant que les gens et son
rang avec 2000 francs par mois
eh ben ça sera toujours la galère pour
payer les df pour payer l'eau pour
manger certains mois comme ici à
bordeaux une trentaine d'antennes
assedic ont été occupées dans toute la
france les élections passées le
mouvement des chômeurs tente de
reprendre l'initiative sur le terrain
social
d'autres actions sont en préparation
pour les jours à venir
vaccin contre l'hépatite b met-il en
danger la santé des français qu'ils ont
reçu c'est la question qui est posée
après une campagne de vaccination
pratiquement systématiques menées ces
dernières années sans dramatiser il faut
savoir que le vaccin est désormais sous
très haute surveillance et des études
sont en cours pour déterminer si oui ou
non il peut présenter un danger chez
certaines personnes
enquête olivier galzi lawrence elodie 13
ans et malade
une maladie qui au fil des ans atrophie
ses muscles et lui fait perdre son
équilibre
les symptômes sont apparus tout de suite
après la première injection du vaccin
contre l'hépatite b est ce un hasard
sa mère s'interroge et réclame des
explications des grands en se pencher
sur le problème
parce que ça fait déjà 10 ans qu'on
vaccine et que les causes s'accumulent
s'accumulent il faut vraiment y ait une
enquête des pouvoirs publics
cette enquête le docteur jacky bovine
cela réclame aussi des bons jours à
travers son association il a recensé
plus de 700 cas qui comme elodie ont été
victimes de maladies graves à la suite
de leur vaccination aujourd'hui son
association le revahb réclame une
évaluation du vaccin
quotidiennement nous avons des dizaines
d'appels de personnes qui signalent des
effets secondaires survenus dans les
semaines ou dans les jours qui suivent
une injection vaccinale
vous avez l'impression d'avoir du mal à
être entendu nous commençons aujourd'hui
à être écouté par les pouvoirs publics
l' agence du médicament nous a reçus il
ya quelques jours et à partager nos
préoccupations par rapport à ce problème
de vaccins
l' agence du médicament c'est
l'organisme français qui à travers cet
homme autorise ou non la mise sur le
marché de tout médicament vaccin y
compris pour évaluer un médicament la
règle est simple c'est celle du risque
bénéfice car le risque zéro en médecine
n'existe pas il faut donc le calcul est
à l'aune du bénéfice pour la population
générale
dans le cas du vaccin contre l'hépatite
b -les agences du médicament constate
elle aussi une recrudescence des
signalements des signalements
suffisamment graves et nombreux pour
qu'elle ait récemment décidé de
mobiliser le quart de ses effectifs sur
le problème mais notification qui nous a
réunis mais les plaintes et des
personnes qui ont été touchées par une
maladie doivent être prises en
considération et c'est ce que nous
faisons au continent le travail à la
recherche de quelque chose qui l'instant
n'a pu être n'a pu être du temps ni
démontrer ni infirmé il y a donc un
doute
et pourtant les autorités sanitaires
françaises continuent à promouvoir le
vaccin
vous revenez me voir en disant mais il
ya des doutes j'admets qu'il ya des
doutes je vous remercie de les signaler
nous les connaissons nous sommes très
attentifs et les doutes d'un côté et les
morts de l'autre les morts de l'hépatite
b en france il y en avait mille par an
94 selon le réseau officiel de santé
publique
le même chiffre qu'aujourd'hui malgré
les 20 millions de vaccinés alors à la
mutualité française on s'interroge on
s'interroge sur l'utilité de la
vaccination de masse fallait-il vraiment
vacciner tout le monde comme on l'a fait
en france beaucoup beaucoup de gens
étaient vaccinés qu'il ne courait aucun
risque d'être contaminé ainsi selon la
mutualité plusieurs millions de français
pour qui le risque d'attraper la maladie
était quasi nul aurait été vaccinées
abusivement surcoût pour la sécurité
sociale 2 milliards de francs pour la
seule année 95
pourquoi en est on arrivé là pour
répondre à cette question il faut
remonter à 1994
dans les collèges notamment philippe
douste-blazy alors ministre de la santé
lance une grande campagne d'éradication
de la maladie
une aubaine pour les fabricants de
vaccins qui à l'image de ce spot
publicitaire vont alors dépenser des
millions pour informer sur la maladie
détection le vaccin informé une parfois
désinformer ainsi cette plaquette de
pasteur mérieux qui déclare la salive
est un important vecteur de
contamination
une affirmation pour le moins alarmiste
aucun cas de contamination par la salive
n'a jamais été observé alors pourquoi ce
mensonge
le but est écrit noir sur blanc dans ce
document interne de chez pasteur mérieux
sur le marché de la vaccination les
adolescents sont un segment très porteur
il faut dramatiser en clair il faut
faire peur avec la maladie on a menti
donc pour faire de l'argent
du côté des laboratoires c'est très
clair et puis on a menti au niveau de
nos instances dirigeants pour montrer
qu'on était capable de combattre une
maladie qui ressemble étrangement sida
donc comment peut pas faire grand chose
pour le sida je pense que dans l'esprit
des gens faire quelque chose pour une
maladie qui est le cousin germain du
sida ça rassure
l'organisation mondiale de la santé dans
les différents pays industrialisés a
conseillé une vaccination contre
l'hépatite b
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
donc d'autres pays d'ailleurs développé
cette vaccination
le fait que les laboratoires derrière
publie des plaquettes parfois
mensongères sur la maladie pour vendre
leurs vaccins cela ne dérange pas il
faut combattre toute publication
mensongère mais au delà de la politique
commerciale des laboratoires n'est
pouvoirs publics rappelle que sans le
vaccin plusieurs milliers de personnes
auraient été contaminées par l'hépatite
b et parmi elles plusieurs centaines
seraient mortes
autant la question se pose aujourd'hui
de savoir si oui ou non le vaccin
comporte un risque pour certaines
personnes
si tel était le cas l'effet
démultiplicateur sur près de 20 millions
de vaccinés soulèverait alors une autre
question
le calcul risque/bénéfice propres atouts
vaccins at il été bien effectué au
procès de maurice papon à bordeaux début
des plaidoiries de la défense maître
francis villemin l'assistant de m e
varaut a essayé de définir la
personnalité de maurice papon et son
passé de résistant dominique verdeilhan
françois prieur la peur au ventre
francis vuillemin 29 ans s'apprête à
prononcer sa première plaidoirie
est ce que ça représente j'ai peur de
quoi
chargé par de la salle g pôle deschepper
du rôle que j'ai assumée j'ai peur j'ai
confiance à la fois c'est une sensation
étrange venu le soutenir pour cette
première ses parents son ami durant six
mois il fut dans l'ombre de m e varaut
mais à l'audience il choisira de
s'asseoir aux côtés de maurice papon
dans le box 60 ans séparent les deux
hommes et durant trois heures m villemin
choisi de réhabiliter l'homme un boxeur
de 87 ans qui dit il ne se laisse pas
abattre
à la fin de la plaidoirie maurice papon
laisse percevoir quelques larmes
m e varaut fils ici son jeune confrère
et quelques applaudissements se font en
temps
il a pris mes mains dans ses mains en me
remerciant disant qu'il avait des bus et
qu'effectivement il avait rarement il se
laissait rarement allé surtout en public
puisque c'est quelqu'un de pudique je
vous le dis qu'il aurait voulu retenir
ses larmes il n'y est pas parvenu
j'en éprouve une certaine fierté
a bordeaux m arno klarsfeld n'est donc
plus le seul à signer des autographes
maurice papon résistant et humaniste
c'est le portrait qu'a voulu dresser le
jeune avocat
il reste à jean marc varaut durant les
trois jours qui viennent à s'attaquer
aux cinquante mille pages du dossier de
l'accusation
l'actualité internationale pour son
retour au kremlin ce matin après une
semaine de repos le président boris
elstine a décidé de limoger purement et
simplement son premier ministre viktor
tchernomyrdine et l'ensemble du
gouvernement s'agit-il d'une sanction ou
une manière de le mettre en position du
succès des c'est bien là la question
moscou gilles rabin jean françois renaud
en entendant les premières paroles de
boris eltsine venue vendredi dernier
faire un tour au kremlin ont montré
qu'il n'est plus malade il aurait dû se
méfier je vais faire remarquer que des
couloirs où tu es complètement vive n'y
avait personne
on m'a dit mais non de temps en temps il
ya quelqu'un qui passe chaque fois que
la maladie de les cartes de pouvoir à
son retour boris eltsine une menace de
limoger 9 3 min c'est si souvent le même
scénario qu'à moscou on en rit
ouvertement on en riait
car s'il est vrai que eltsine craint par
dessus tout que sa faiblesse physique se
traduisent par un affaiblissement
politique le limogeage du gouvernement
tout entier ce matin n'était pas à cupet
les un coup de théâtre préméditée depuis
longtemps exide et or tchernomirdine
premier ministre à la longévité record
qui venait d'inaugurer une cause il
télévisée hebdomadaire pour faire
remonter sa cote de popularité
arrive un quasi-inconnu sergei kiriyenko
35 ans banquier choisi pour rassurer le
fonds monétaire international et les
investisseurs étrangers
bon et ceci n'est qu'un premier ministre
qui devenait chaque jour un peu plus un
rival
pourquoi faire reprendre le pouvoir
perdu pendant ces prolongations et
briguer un troisième mandat
en l'an 2000 ou bien pour mettre en
selle le successeur dont il rêve qu'il
dit avoir déjà choisi sans jamais avoir
voulu révéler son nom pas de réponse à
cette question ce soir car le coup de
théâtre 4 un coup de poker de
poker-menteur bien sûr au kosovo au
lendemain du vote clandestins qui a
donné une majorité quasi absolu au
leader indépendantiste une manifestation
regroupant cette fois ci plusieurs
milliers de serbes a eu lieu aujourd'hui
en réaction donc à ce vote d'hier
laurent boussier jean-jacques le garrec
reportage en voiture en bus drapeaux au
vent et klaxons hurlants ils sont venus
de toute la région pour participer à
cette manifestation
première réponse des serbes aux
élections clandestine albanaise dire
officiellement il s'agissait de
s'opposer aux accords signés ce matin
sur l'accès des universités de christina
aux étudiants albanais nous manifestons
parce que la serbie ne doit pas céder
aux albanais aucun pays aux moines mais
réserve sa diversité à une minorité
vingt-cinq à trente mille personnes ce
qui est beaucoup pour une communauté ne
représentant que 10 % de la population
du kosovo des slogans nationalistes mais
aucun débordement comme si personne ne
voulait porter la responsabilité aux
dérapages ne cherche pas la guerre on le
veut chasser personnes on veut bien
vivre ensemble
mais dans un seul pays et avec une seule
loi les élections hier côté albanais
cette manifestation imposante
aujourd'hui que des serbes
une fois que chaque camp a démontré sa
force les négociations vont peut-être
pouvoir commencer l'arrivée annoncée
d'un envoyé du président
davies ici à priscilla est un signe
positif puis la tension est telle entre
les communautés que la moindre étincelle
peut dégénérer en guerre civile
le président américain arrive sur le
continent africain une visite commencée
par le ghana les états unis
s'intéressent à nous à l'afrique donc
avec cette formule nous ne voulons pas
aidé à fonds perdus mais faire des
affaires avec les africains
à son arrivée le président clinton face
à une foule exubérante a dû faire la
police lui même et son sourire
légendaire vous allez loire a disparu
pendant quelques instants alors qu'il
essayait de dégager de se dégager de la
foule présente à son arrivée
le pape jean paul ii lui a quitté le
continent africain ce soir le nigeria au
terme d'un voyage de trois jours qui sur
le plan politique l'a amené à demander à
la junte militaire au pouvoir de
respecter des droits de l'homme dans le
pays discours prononcé devant une foule
de plus de 700 mille personnes avant son
départ sur place alain chalon c'est la
chanson du nigeria pour jean paul ii le
papier l'esprit de l'esprit saint rien
de moins
jean paul ii se serait sans doute bien
passé de ce compliment mais la chanson
est significative de l'espoir que les
nigérians ont placé dans sa visite il a
parlé des droits de il a parlé de
réconciliation et des aspirations des
habitants de ce pays à être plus près
les uns des autres et nous croyons que
le chef d'état il est leader du pays de
même que le peuple ne peuvent pas rester
sourd à tous et de fête hier soir jean
paul ii à une rencontre positive avec
les chefs traditionnels musulmans du
pays
rencontre qui n'avait pas pu avoir lieu
lors de son précédent voyage il ya 16
ans c'est qu'aujourd'hui les musulmans
comme les chrétiens doivent faire face
ici un nouveau défi celui des cercles
dans cette petite ville de carmaux par
exemple au près d'abuja
il y à une vingtaine de sec que pour
quelques dizaines de milliers
d'habitants et parmi celles ci
ce centre des miracles goût de beaucoup
de gens ne peuvent pas aller à l'hôpital
car ils ne peuvent pas payer la facture
il pense dans ses églises des miracles
car elle prétend faire des miracles
ils pensent trouver une oreille
attentive à leurs problèmes physiques ou
psychologiques club
il pense aussi qu'ils vont guérir le
phénomène est encore nouveau les églises
catholiques sont toujours pleines au
point que l'on assiste même parfois à la
messe de l'extérieur mais ce phénomène
est suffisamment inquiétant pour avoir
été sans doute une des raisons
essentielles de ce voyage épuisant de
jean paul ii au nigeria
dans l'entourage de jean paul ii on est
satisfait de ce voyage le succès
populaire avec 2 millions de personnes à
osny cha a été au delà de ce que l'on
espérait le dialogue avec les musulmans
est enfin ouvert et positif quant à la
petite graine sur les droits de l'homme
planté par jean paul ii et bien on
espère qu'elle sera géré mais dans le
futur
le sport avec les avions d'air france
aux couleurs de la coupe du monde de
football que la compagnie parraine
officiellement sur ces avions figureront
des joueurs de différentes équipes en
présence de par appareil un de chaque
côté du fuselage et ça pendant toute la
durée de la coupe du monde jusqu'à la
fin du mois de juillet la route de l'or
à la voile christophe auguin est arrivé
à san francisco 5 jours après yves
parlier le vainqueur et quatre heures à
peine après isabelle autissier qui a
donc bien failli être rattrapé juste sur
la ligne d'arrivée quatre ans seulement
d' avance pour isabelle autissier devant
les stocks ou bien cette nuit hollywood
seront décernés les 70e oscars du cinéma
archi-favori le titanic un naufrage qui
a donc fait un triomphe et qui est
présenté dans le monde entier y compris
dans des pays où normalement la censure
s'exerce assez sévèrement notamment sur
le cinéma américain c'est le cas au
caire en egypte la balle et s'en sort
n'ont donc pas pu empêcher le triomphe
de titanic et charbit en arabe comme en
anglais le titre d'un succès universel
traité à la mode orientale
kate winslet et leonardo dicaprio les
acteurs vedettes du film ont eu droit à
leur mur pas dans les rues du caire
dans ce cinéma du centre de la ville on
est prêt à payer 15 livres c'est à dire
28 francs le dixième du salaire de base
égyptien pour assister à la projection
du film sur réservation 4 à 5 jours
d'attentes 15 livres pour vivre et aux
aventures d'un pauvre immigré italien
amoureux d'une riche irlandaise sur fond
de film catastrophe
j'en ai le souffle coupé le film est
extraordinaire j'ai l'impression que je
pourrais rester trois ou quatre heures
sans toi viens moi c'est un film
fabuleux c'est la quatrième fois que je
le vois magnifique la musique la
validation les acteurs vraiment
splendide en egypte ont connu une
l'histoire à la banque sarasin du film
le héros l'emportent tout le temps dans
ce film c'est tout contre
même la stricte censure égyptienne
malgré des scènes pour le moins
sensuelle s'est laissé séduire par
l'histoire des deux amants quant au
réalisateur égyptien
ils ne peuvent rivaliser avec hollywood
mais se félicite du retour du public
dans les salles en tant que cinéaste
marchés qu'il ya vraiment des gens vont
découvrir quoi ce que c'est qu'une salle
de cinéma ce que c'est qu'un une grande
image je suis content
la fin du film la fin du rêve un rêve
américain en terre africaine
un rêve à 250 millions de dollars un
milliard et demi de francs
de quoi financer la production de plus
de 200 films égyptiens le cinéma avec
encore avec la sortie cette semaine d'un
film de science fiction de barry
levinson ce faire avec une distribution
prestigieuse liste enough man peter
coyote et la très belle sharon stone
stéphanois prenaient vingt mille lieues
sous les mers
une épave mystérieuse des scientifiques
à la recherche d'un dangereux aliens et
mélanger suaire est un cocktail connu
une sorte d'alice bis avec de gros
poissons
dustin hoffman samuel jackson et une
sirène sharon stone pour tous cours de
plongée obligatoire et prises de vues
pendant des semaines au fond d'un bassin
alphabet c'était fabuleux
la seule personne qui pouvait me parler
dans le scaphandre c'était le
réalisateur je me sentais en pcie eyed
peas en paix enfin jusqu'au moment où
les scientifiques découvrent cette
sphère étrange qui leur fait tout
simplement perdre la boule
il est en train de dérailler dans
l'habitat normal nous prenons l'eau
à 40 ans sharon stone sex symbol
revendique une nouvelle image plus sage
en vieillissant vous changez de n'y a
rien de pire qu'une femme qui essaye de
garder la même thèse pendant 20 ans car
c'est toujours avant comme tu es belle
il faut savoir passer à autre chose pour
rester soi même
netapp a dit ce qu'il y a dans ce qu'on
ne lui avait pas dit il n'y avait pas
dit ce qu'il ya dans la serre entre
science-fiction huit clos psychologique
ce faire est une plongée dans les eaux
troubles de la conscience
un film parfois naïf adapté d'un roman
américain de michael crichton monsieur
jurassic park a décidément une passion
pour les mondes engloutis
avant nous quitter le rappel des
principaux titres de l'actualité avec
d'abord le président la république
jacques chirac qui s'est exprimé à
propos des problèmes posés par le front
national pour la droite du lit la fin ne
justifie pas les moyens pour la gauche
elle a jeté de l'huile sur le feu et a
joué le jeu de l'extrême droite
quant au fn a dit monsieur jacques
chirac c'est un parti raciste et
xénophobe présidence des conseils
régionaux la région provence alpes côte
d'azur est passé à gauche donc ce matin
toulouse et rouen et lé président rpr
udf élu avec les voix du fn ont
démissionné à paris rien n'est encore
réglé ce soit dans un instant la météo
sophie davant que vous retrouvez
désormais chaque soir également avant le
journal de 20h à ne pas manquer
20h50 spéciale d'un monde à l'autre
thème la violence dans les sociétés avec
vers 21h40 le film l'appât fourie disney
le débat mené par paul amar demain 7h 50
dans les 4 vérités
marie pierre farkas recevoir ariel
sharon une stricte règne des
infrastructures nationales quant à moi
je vous retrouverai à 20 heures je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur la
prochaine on soin
autre